just going to make a brief statement as
most of you i think know
judge penny today
after a hearing
decided to
agree with britney spears
and as of today effective immediately
the conservatorship has been terminated
as to both
the person and the estate
[Applause]
this is a
monumental
day for britney spears
it's also a somber day
for me for brittany
and i think for a lot of us
who have been following conservatorships
and how they operate
this conservatorship
was corrupted
by james p spears
james p spears as we all know
from public records
he took a salary from the estate
he took a percentage of his daughter's
earnings
from las vegas and otherwise
many people have asked about
whether we will continue to investigate
mr spears
the answer ultimately is up to my client
brittany
and i'm not going to get into it beyond
that
i've also received a lot of questions
about britney spears
business manager
tristar and my comments are going to be
brief about tristar
all i will say for present purposes is
this
we were forced to issue two subpoenas
to tri-star
sports and entertainment
because they wouldn't voluntarily
cooperate with britney spears
that is why we issued subpoenas to
tristar
rather than voluntarily complying with
those subpoenas
tristar refused
and they filed a motion to suppress
those subpoenas
and suppress information
that britney spears has requested
the most notable question that we've
asked on behalf of brittany of tristar
is the following a very simple question
how much money
did you take from the estate
how much money did you receive from the
estate
tristar
and i'm not drawing any conclusions
right now
but you can draw your own inference
has refused to answer that question
i just want to circle back to britney
i'm so proud of her
i thank her i thank her for her
courage and poise
and power
i thank her for our relationship
not only is this momentous for brittany
but she helped shine
light
on not only this conservatorship was
which was corrupted
by her father james p spears
but she helped shine a light
on conservatorships and guardianships
from coast to coast
from california to new york
and that took a tremendous amount of
insight
courage
and grace
if there are any questions i'll take a
couple of questions
what's next for brittany
and this is the first time this could be
said for about a decade
is up to one person brittany
i i will say i i will say that britney
has been put into a position
through our collaboration and the work
of my law firm to succeed
we have a safety net in place for
brittany both on the personal side
and on the financial side as those of
you who are in court understand
but brittany as of today
is a free woman
and she's an independent woman
and the rest with her support system
will be up to brittany
we believe it was the right result
britney
specifically requested that there be no
mental evaluation and the judge did not
require it we
whether britney performs again whether
britney performs again
will be up to brittany at the right time
[Music]
i'm sorry would you represent me out
there
i haven't been asked and that's not
something i would get into right now
can you just clarify what happens here
in the conservatorship from here how
much control does brittany have and what
kind of transitions are we looking at
over the next month well as of today as
judge penny ruled on the record
her language was
in effect the conservatorship of the
person
and the conservatorship of the estate
are terminated effective today
subject to
a couple of conditions subsequent
and what that means is we have set up a
financial safety net for brittany in
terms of a new trust all of the assets
that are outside of the existing trust
will be transferred by the existing
conservator of the estate
who replaced jamie spears who was
suspended and grace into that trust so
that's one safety net that's in place
for brittany
well that's not something i'm going to
comment on in detail but anybody who
saw the new york times documentary
and it was mocked by james spears
attorney as a tv show it wasn't a tv
show it was a highly vetted documentary
or read the new york times front page
expose
knows that the conduct as alleged by the
times which was corroborated by the
times deserves investigation
i used to be a federal prosecutor now
i'm just a private attorney i don't have
criminal investigative powers what
happens there will be up to law
enforcement
not up to
that's what we've asked tristar how much
do you think yeah i'm not going to
comment
i'm not going to comment
one would think that a business manager
if asked by their client
would respond and give them that number
their response has been well it's in the
accountings
i would ask does tristar treat all of
their clients this way or is it just
britney spears
she's been bullied for a decade and why
tristar is continuing to bully britney
spears is a fair question i don't have
the answer to that
tristar will have to answer that
[Music]
mr zabal has remaining powers in terms
of winding up his responsibilities as
reflected on the
record this is up to law enforcement is
law enforcement
she's aware of the result though
that's up to britney spears
it's an amendment to the existing trust
i was proud to
be in the right place at the right time
i'm not going to comment in terms of
details in regards to how we got
together has there been a family member
not going to comment on that
hear the question but uh yes the
conservatorship was 13 years
brittany herself testified in court as
everybody knows both on june 23rd and
july 14th in regards to the abuse that
she says she suffered at the hands of
her father james p spears one other
comment i'll make unless there are any
other specific questions is this many
journalists have
speculated or commented in regard to
james p spears
i haven't spoken with journalists on
this particular point but it is correct
that we served a notice of deposition
uh to require james p spears to testify
under oath on october 20th
that did not happen
he refused to appear
we served another deposition notice for
him to appear under oath and answer
questions asked by myself
and my law firm on november 12th he also
did not appear excuse me on november
10th he did not appear on november 10th
either if britney wants
if britney instructs we will pursue
james spears deposition
we will pursue the discovery that we
served on him in the form of
interrogatories document requests
and other information we're seeking both
in regards to financial information
alleged financial misconduct and the
electronic surveillance issue
you can draw your own inference on that
i will say that i will say this i
apologize
it's interesting that he has refused to
cooperate because his lawyer
in his lawyer's filing
claimed that mr spears would profusely
cooperate
i can say this
they have not responded to one document
request they have not responded to one
interrogatory and they have refused thus
far to appear for deposition under oath
a cross-examination of an individual or
witness under oath at a deposition
any lawyer will tell you is how you find
the truth
i'm looking forward to that deposition
why he has not appeared why he's ducking
the deposition is something he and his
council will have to answer
i'm going to give the same boring answer
and that's up to brittany
we've seen britney she wore a free
britney teacher last night
those are britney's communications
[Music]
as well
i've got a client who i need to speak
with and i just want to thank everybody
for their support defense
media involvement
thank you very much